well we need to have the conversation
about vegetables it's so prevalent in my
life right now like you know of course
Paul you know he
vehemently yeah he's maybe not
venomently but he doesn't eat his
vegetables there's lots of those kinds
of people and and that are talking about
you know oxalates and sort of the
chemical the the chemical fighting
um markers it has to remain a plant on a
bush so it doesn't die so lectins of
course are such a popular one that so
many especially gundry have made popular
um or well known about so what is the
role of vegetables then
yeah so go ahead just be divisive it's
totally fine well opinions yeah well
it's not generally my nature to want to
be too polarizing so I will I will start
by just validating I love that you have
an opinion you you listening to it I do
great because you you are happy but I
also get the impression from you that no
matter what you're okay to change your
opinion if the science or if the oh yeah
data tells you something different and
so I think as human beings as we go
along in life we I have lots of things
that I believe in tell you what I didn't
believe in them back you know a year ago
or five years ago and that changes for
every aspect of my life so we have to we
have to kind of practice something so
right now what is that practice and
awareness yeah yeah well thanks that's a
nice way of saying it yeah I mean I am
I'm a scientist which means I'm a seeker
of Truth and I'm constantly trying to
prove theories false unlike
some scientists these days where it's
become you know almost a religious sort
of fervor
um but never I mean the nature of a
scientist is to prove things wrong I
feel like that's totally your guys's
domain you come up with a theory you you
test it out the math the science works
and then EV there is like almost it
seems I don't know how many multiples of
effort but there's so many multiples of
effort that go into disproving it you
guys like are a culture of like trying
to vet things out wrong it's bad well
we're supposed to be I'm I I don't know
that we are as much as we used to uh and
there's a very interesting well that's a
tangent that touches on kind of cultural
issues here but I mean there's
definitely a trend for that where
science is um kind of turning into a bit
of a religious fervor now I don't say
that to denigrate religion I'm myself
very religious
um but uh but I but to me these are
different things and and I think that to
in too many instances nowadays
um when when there is an a kind of
ardent
um zealous proclamation of you know I
believe the science or I believe in
science I think belief should have
nothing to do with it
it is it is this cold analytical process
of what are the newest data and does it
does it refute or how does it challenge
the hypothesis that I was operating
under before that and people have not
wanted to continue to do that they've
had some evidence that they believe
shows their theory is valid and then
they're done that might be why they say
I believe the science is because they
say I believe what I found is what's
true no you cannot say that as a
scientist or if you want to be
kind of thinking like a scientist does
or what I should just say is any
rational person but nevertheless
um to the question about vegetables
I will validate the the concerns that
some people have expressed
um there are indeed such things known as
anti-nutrients in in plants that will to
some degree or another try to blunt well
try to discourage the animal from eating
them humans included by by among other
possibilities preventing the digestion
or the absorption of whatever nutrients
are in the plant now in our wisdom and
capacity we have bred plants in such a
way that very often these anti-nutrients
are little I mean very I mean I don't
know that you could get rid of them
completely but they would be so minimal
as to not truly disrupt the absorption
of the you know the minerals the
vitamins or some of the nutrients well
the nutrients would only really be the
macronutrients would only be glucose but
even still there are such things as
anti-nutrients I believe people
unwittingly expose themselves to higher
levels of it when they eat concentrated
sources of vegetable matter like P
protein or soy protein if it's not
fermented we know that those
anti-nutrients can get enriched in those
protein sources ironically making it so
you can't even digest The Limited amino
acids you think you're getting so which
is why I'm vehemently opposed to plant
protein as a supplement because plants
are so deficient in protein in general
that you have to take say a thousand
peas and concentrate them to get the
amino acid
um serving size that you want but while
you're concentrating your mind yeah well
that's it's because what we've it's
unnatural mankind humans are not meant
to get proteins from Plants because
plants don't have protein yeah you would
be protein deficient which is why you
get a thousand peas distill them for
their amino acids but in the process of
concentrating and concentrating you end
up concentrating anti-nutrients and
heavy metals which is why lead an
arsenic can be elevated in plant
proteins yeah these These are in a way
it's common sense and this has all been
validated there's third-party entities
that have tested the amount of heavy
metals in protein supplements and plant
proteins just steal it by a mile they
are the big offenders now I don't mean
for this to say
that no one should ever be a vegan
knowledge is power though but I can't
apologize if it sounds like I'm saying
that because humans are not meant to be
vegan and veganism is a privilege of the
elite where you have to be educated
enough to know what your deficiencies
will be because you will have
deficiencies there's no questioning that
and you have to be wealthy enough to
afford the high quality supplements to
make up for it so if you can do that all
right well then all right high five
you're gonna be fine hopefully but you
have to meet those two things and so
don't be telling other people to do it
if they don't have the knowledge and
they don't have the means to afford the
supplements to make up for it so it's
two parts but
coming back to the idea of the
anti-nutrients they are genuine real
things the heavy metals that get
enriched when you concentrate the plants
although that wouldn't be a concern in
just eating an apple but that still
doesn't change the fact that there's
nothing utterly essential to them now
there might be something I've been
stewing over in my head what you said
about Mindy and the thought about
measuring progesterone there's a part of
me that would think all right I mean
insofar as progesterone is a hormone
that of course is essential to gestation
and pregnancy that's pro-gestation you
can't get pregnant without progesterone
you can't carry that little baby oh you
wouldn't really ovulate in the first
place normally without it or have a
normal ovulatory cycle progesterone is
among its many effects it wants fat
cells to grow
um but but it can't do that without
insulin's help and so maybe there is
something to be said for getting a
little modest insulin Spike from time to
time and that enabling progesterone to
do what it needs to do among many things
which is want fat cells to grow or want
to store more fat which is one of
progesterone's effects independent of
ovulation it is a it is a fat storage
hormone so maybe there's something to be
said for it but by and large there's
nothing you know kind of
quintessentially important or rather
essential
um to the carbohydrate so my view is
they they are this is a food well plants
vegetables to be more precise because
that's how you brought this question up
I think vegetables are things that can
be enjoyed and and maybe even used
deliberately with a purpose for to a
healthy end
um and that's why I'm very warm to
vegetables eaten not not don't drink
them of course don't juice them
um but but in general I would still say
the bulk of what's coming in should be
protein and fat yeah is there any uh
final thought on the vegetables is there
anything that you can't get from the fat
and protein
um from vitamins minerals micronutrients
standpoint that you would need a
vegetable for
well we're pushing the limits of what I
know because I'm not a dietitian you
know I'm a nutrient kind of biochemist
but
um it would be I can't readily think of
one like for example people would say
well you got to get a banana for
potassium well you can get plenty of
potassium from other things they would
say well you got to get leafy greens for
vitamin K well you'll get much better
vitamin K from cheese or any kind of
fermented dairy they would say you got
to get calcium from this well you'll get
calcium from you know Dairy of course or
what's a vitamin C I'll say well I don't
have vitamin C you will you will get
scurvy and so you have to eat um citrus
fruits well
um the the funny thing there is you use
vitamin C to make collagen that's it's
that's what the C stands for and so if
you're already eating a lot of collagen
because you're eating meat well then you
make less collagen and you don't need a
lot of vitamin C so the little teeny bit
you get from meat is more than enough
yeah
um but yeah fiber fiber is not essential
there's no question about that it's just
essential if people have a particular
affection for stool habits you know for
bowel movement habits you know but but
you don't need it you will still have
bowel movements on a purely carnivore
diet they will just be smaller and less
frequent and you will have no gas I mean
there's no flatulence on a carnivore
diet at all
wins and losses yeah so that's why every
wife wants her husband to be on a
carnivore diet amen just kind of maybe
to share what what your most important
practices and beliefs are right now for
your health one kind of Mantra or or
idea that keeps me grounded and enjoying
life is to take my duties seriously but
not myself
if that makes sense and so while I
appreciate the duties and obligations
that I have as a husband father as a
professor as a scientist as as a you
know part of my my congregation in my
neighborhood at church I take all that
very seriously but I don't take myself
seriously and I don't think others
particularly seriously which allows me
to laugh at my mistakes to find the
humor in the chaos of life and little
kids and laugh at those mistakes so if a
kid drops a cup of water on the ground
don't immediately scold and reprimand
and get angry laugh about it and
acknowledge that that was an accident
that kid didn't want to dump that cup
over
um and so again take your duties
seriously but not yourself that to me is
a key to well I don't know it'll make
life long and healthy but it will
certainly make it more enjoyable
[Music]
foreign